there is a slow motion crisis unfolding
in new orleans where they survived the
impact of ida but now face weeks living
like this
in the sweltering summer humidity queues
growing at one of the few places in town
with petrol and the warning it could be
a month before the electricity is back
on our thoughts go out to everybody that
has been impacted by this devastating
storm for now they rely on the wind-up
radio the generosity of those with
generators and that famous new orleans
resilience it's a big mess and most
people have left town
i think part of that is due to the power
outages these power things i mean it
seems
crazy that it could be weeks
what do you think about that
i think i wonder if i should leave
but i think they're people who are a lot
worse off than
than we are
but ida left at least one horrifying
story behind a man apparently killed by
an alligator in front of his wife
outside his flooded home in this
neighborhood it wasn't the danger from
ida they'd expected here it really
freaked us out because it's only one
road over from ours it's like on the
next road over and so
just the thought of an alligator being
loose out here
terrifies me i ain't gonna lie to you i
mean the thought of that what happened
to that poor guy is really really sad
though you know i mean
i can't even imagine what he or she went
through
moore died when part of a road gave way
in torrential rain in mississippi across
the region officials expect the number
to rise
most of the hospitals do have emergency
power but already swamped with a surge
in covert cases before ida they're
worried of a further spread in the chaos
for many even the basics of a hot meal
are welcome and frustrations growing
because they thought new orleans had
learned lessons from hurricanes past
what did einstein say keep doing the
same thing and expecting the different
results is insanity and that's what we
have we pay electricity bill that's
upwards of four hundred dollars a month
and now we don't have electricity i was
born and raised in new orleans and new
orleans people are resilient
and we're going to get through this
we always do so just just hang tight god
is on our side
this is a city that's had more than its
share of adversity